i didn't decide not to go to the white
house after the super bowl
i said it before the game everybody else
jumped on the bandwagon after the game
i just don't [ __ ] with the president if
anybody invite me to their house
that i don't want to eat their food i
ain't going and he looks like somebody
who i don't want to eat their food
looks like going to go have lunch with
darth vader
[Laughter]
[Music]
so who we got in the pool hall today we
got a good friend marty b what's good
with you baby not much
i'm just still on this side with things
that are going on in the world
we got enough space between us over here
man go ahead let me see how nice you are
though i really am more
to pull tricks okay i like to watch
people do that stuff like the black
widow she was cold
but i just feel like this is a weird
game for you to pick anyway who the [ __ ]
picks pull
as activity between two men to have a
conversation hey it's just weird to me
like you for some reason 2.5 million
people want to watch this [ __ ]
so look what the hell is that did you
make anything i didn't make it it's my
first shot
when you look back at that super bowl
season take me through that year what do
you remember from that year
they started with getting traded i was
at disney world when i got the call
to say i was going to be traded so then
my daughter's birthday was around and we
were going to disney world bill
belichick called me
and he's like hey we need to get you out
here for physical whatever i'm like well
coach i'm at disney world right now i
literally cannot come
and i'm trying to enjoy disney world
with my family you know mickey's there
goofy's there everyone's there you know
just like these guys are great and at
the same time i've been traded
bill called me back it's like well we
got to get you out here otherwise the
trade won't go through if we don't get
the physical and i was just kind of like
well that sounds like a youth thing
but then my agent called me he's like
hey no you gotta go
you gotta go and i was like i can't go
tomorrow like two days from now like why
i gotta stop my life
right now to fly to [ __ ] boston to go
see this [ __ ]
and go do an mri for them like i'm here
right now i'm trying to i'm in disney
world for crying out loud not like
daughter's birthday yeah they don't give
a [ __ ] but then tom calls me
tom brady tom brady yeah tom we all
don't have a personal one-on-one
connection with tom brady just called
tom
well me and tom became cool because of i
love her interior design
what we bonded over pinterest um wait
you see what tom brady would just search
tom calls me and he was like man i'm so
excited about getting you out here and
i'll just kind of like
yeah but tom do i have to go out there
right now because i feel like they're
kind of making this [ __ ] up right now i
don't know how this goes like do i have
to come
he's like yeah but you kind of have to
go do that right now i was like
all right how'd that season go for
someone like you as you're talking about
your career i mean that season for a lot
of people was a season
many people won't forget even the casual
fan remembers that patriot season for me
i think that was the most fun i've ever
had playing football
from peewee to just any time on any team
it was just fun like all the guys were
cool
no one bothered me about like what i was
doing or if i was at art museums or
whatever
and i respected the way that they
treated people like men
right a lot of these coaches talk to
players as if they're boys
right like i got a wife and kid coach
what the [ __ ] you talking about man
did you ever grow up want to be a super
bowl champion that's a tough question
because
i don't think it was my idea of it first
person that i experienced it was when my
brother won a super bowl
and he told me he's like it's like
having another child so when my brother
won
we were talking about it and first of
all he's an [ __ ] and i was in seattle
like i was standing at his house i was
like hey man you got some of that orange
juice he's like yeah
go get some about the refrigerator i
opened it there's the super bowl trophy
you know so he just had this thing like
you get in the cars
in the car with him you know what i'm
saying he's like yo this is the greatest
feeling ever
et cetera et cetera et cetera and so for
me i'm like damn that sounds good like i
want to feel that
but it was different in new england
going into the super bowl what was that
experience like yeah we're getting ass
kicked i mean what the [ __ ] what the
falcons doing they were celebrating
one thing i remember i think it was two
chains that came down like after
halftime like
that i remember their sideline more so
than like our sideline
two chainz ti it was like everybody you
imagine being at the strip club without
the strippers man tupac was probably on
that sideline
because looking at their sideline you
like these [ __ ] really think
they won
already take me through the second half
like during that comeback as it happens
what's going on in your mind as you see
the falcons slipping this thing that's
the whole thing
nothing i was like water and all my
teammates were like water
basically it was just like so focused
and enter a space of flow that i never
experienced in sports before in fact
when we
won i had to ask tom brady i said yo
todd
did we win he's like yeah we we're
champions i said oh
[ __ ] you didn't know you won we
championed all of the [ __ ] overtime
rules in super bowl should be changing
i'm telling you bro i was in flow like i
don't know what the score is
right i had no idea like i just that was
my only time of like really
like snapping out of flow because i'm
looking around and guys running around
we all crying and i don't know why i'm
crying my brother comes down and i think
i was
extra emotional we're super bowl
champions the bennett brothers like who
the [ __ ] say that [ __ ]
i thought you were gonna be really damn
good at this game is how many how many
episodes of this have you done
what's going on your mind in chicago as
now you finally left boston
you've done everything that you had to
do that the super bowl champion does it
may be the pinnacle for somebody but
like
it was never like that pinnacle moment
for my life i actually felt like damn
i've dedicated 20 years of my life for
this [ __ ] god didn't make the world a
better place
right i didn't make any contributions to
changing the world
and the idea of what i feel like should
change it was so then off season you're
sitting in a space where you're like i
spent 20 years doing this it wasn't
worth it what are you doing that off
offseason then i had to get another job
because i was just in between jobs and i
ended up going to the packers which was
[ __ ] disastrous from
day one after that i ended up back with
the patriots
i went to ir but when i went to ir i had
an injury that i couldn't really
fix which was a broken spirit and
there's no type of treatment
that the nfl could provide for a broken
spirit like there's nothing they could
do for me at this point there's nothing
bill belichick can say tom
or the trainer my spirit was broken in a
way that it was something else i was
looking for that
no one in the sporting world could give
me the only thing that could really
truly heal was art
and just making things when i make
things is when i feel most like myself
so after that you know i kind of
rekindled this love i had with japanese
culture
you know i have been studying you know
wabi-sabi and yokai
and shintoism and all these things i
told my wife i was like man i really
feel like i should go to japan
how long are you there for i was there
for 10 days tom brady had a guy over
there named leonard
they put me in connection with basically
all i did was i studied the japanese
culture i prayed to the japanese gods
learned language learned the art i had
my notebook taking notes out drawing
things and like just taking it all in
like i was very present
and it made me reflect like damn why the
[ __ ] do i do something
that i don't love every single part of
after that i came back i retired like a
week after coming back from japan i tell
my wife i was like i'm retiring
so i did a little art piece and i did
that and then i retired but it was
really because of the connection in
japan
with the people you still feel like you
have a broken spirit do i have a broken
spirit hell nah i'm [ __ ] rich as [ __ ]
rich as of mine and spirit i'm the
healthiest i'm a better husband
i didn't want my daughter to grow up
with a football dad because that enigma
could take over what your dad is
my daughter like my dad traveled the
world he spent summers in japan
you know he built video games he changed
the world he brought internet
infrastructure to underserved
communities
that's my legacy right football is not
my legacy and it never was i feel like
i'm a better me without the game of
football
you